now I want you to help me work out what
would this look like for this shape well
pi is pi pi is just a number so it's
always going to stay the same okay where
is the radius on this cylinder where is
it can you draw it in he is the center
right and then the radius of this
cylinder will be this now have a look
what direction does this line this
radius go in it goes up and down right
now I've got two axes here and they have
different names so which axis is the up
and down one this is gonna be the Y
isn't in fact that's what this curve is
this is y equals a particular thing
right so when you want to know how high
it is you say oops wrong color you say Y
now what do we do to the radius in the
formula we square it PI R squared where
in this case the radius is that okay now
what about the width or I should say the
height of this cylinder what is this
thing now this is this infinitesimally
thin width just like I had an
infinitesimally thin width here it's a
width oh it goes horizontally doesn't it
so I go PI R squared in this case my H
is that does that make sense okay see
that object there that's a cylinder one
of them but one of them does not make
the whole solid I need to sum all of
them don't I so thankfully I have good
notation for this I'm going to start
with the smaller cylinder which is over
here I shouldn't say smallest it might
be bigger I'm gonna start with the
leftmost cylinder and then I'm going to
progress all the way through until I get
to the rightmost cylinder like so
that's area this is volume this is the
for Allah for the volume of a solid of
revolution okay
bit of a mouthful but I want you to
remember what this is what are you
adding up
well this 3d shape is basically made of
a whole bunch of cylinders so just add
up a whole bunch of cylinders okay now
don't write this but you will often see
in textbooks and notes from children
colleges and all that kind of thing you
will see this fully written ever so
slightly differently you'll see it
written like this now are these formulas
going to give me the same answer answer
yes because pi is just a number like H
or 19 so you can take numbers constants
out like that okay but I do not like
writing it like this I do not like it
that's why I've written it like this can
you tell me why can you give me a reason
why this is a better way to write it
than this not much of a difference it
will give you the same answer you wrote
lose a mark if use the second one
I like to write things in ways that save
me time or that make things easier
they're all generally things that I like
okay there is not really any time saving
between these two things but what will
happen is when you see this formula and
you're struggling in the middle of an
exam to remember and you're in a rush
you were right this you'll write this
because you're like that's not important
all my brain effort is going here okay I
have seen it thousands of times I'm not
even exaggerating thousands of times
I've had to write forgot the PI forgot
the PI forgot the PI because people
don't think about it it's been taken out
the formula when you see the formula
like this it does two really helpful
things it helps you remember there's a
pie in there don't leave it out okay but
even more importantly than that it
points to me at this this is what you're
dealing with you're dealing with what
kind of objects cylinders you're just
adding up a whole bunch of them I would
prefer to write something in a way that
makes clear what you're doing as opposed
to obscures what you're doing maybe
makes it slightly easier to compute but
like what am I even moving around with
these symbols and so this is what I'm
moving with okay so I'm just going to
jump in at question three partly because
we can hijack the diagram that we used
just now three C involves a volume of a
solid of revolution formed from the area
beneath a parabola okay so it's
literally the same parabola okay
it says calculate the volume generated
when each shaded region just like we
have a shaded region here is rotated
about the x-axis okay so let's have a
look at three say I have a formula over
here and formula over here and one of
the things that we're out a little bit
is that you're integrating something
with wise in it and you're apparently
integrating with respect to X well the
reason why I can do that is because I
usually know what Y is in terms of X so
let's have a go at this for three see
the first thing one right is V equals
because I'm working out of volume and
then I begin to use this formula
integral of where are my boundaries have
a look at the diagram zero and two from
0 to 2 the thing that I'm adding
up is a bunch of cylinders so the very
first thing that appears in the cylinder
formula is our PI so I write down a PI
now the next piece is y squared Y
squared well in this case y is equal to
x squared so when I square everything I
get X to the power of 4 with respect to
X and that was it
the volume formula is not hard to use
there's just some conceptual mechanics
you need to wrap your head around this
is no longer a volume question in a
sense it's just it's just an integral
right you don't need to know anything
about volumes to do this I've got a
definite integral here can someone tell
me what the primitive is PI X to the 5
divided by the new power 5 and then of
course I've got my boundaries 0 & 2
oh but now I can evaluate that looks to
me like 32 pi on 5 as I've pointed out
before but it's worth reminding I have
to do the lower boundary even when it
doesn't actually equal to anything - 0
easy trap to fall into because sometimes
like say for example I had X to the
sorry I had like oh you know X ^ you
know that's a bad example 5 to the power
of X would be a better example well 5 to
the power of X if X was 0 it doesn't
just disappear right that's that's 1 so
please get in the habit of writing the
lower boundary even though a huge
proportion of them will be 0 write it
anyway 32 pi on 5 have I answered the
question I have not so very close what I
need to include this is a volume right
so I would conclude volume is 32 PI on 5
units cubed it's okay if you just write
units cubed on the end but I still like
to write it probably okay